Tesla now says one of its cars involved
in a deadly crash was on autopilot when
it hit a concrete divider the company
says the driver had received several
warnings before the wreck the fiery
crash in California last week follows
another incident in Arizona where an
autonomous car being tested by uber
struck and killed a pedestrian this week
the victim's family reached an
undisclosed settlement with uber and
while that case is settled the concerns
of self-driving cars are not Arizona
suspended ubers driverless car testing
permit for more now we're joined by
Wired's transportation editor Alex
Davies ok Alex good morning thank you
for joining us first off I want to ask
you why Arizona why is this become
Silicon Valley's testing site Arizona
became the popular testing ground for
not just uber but companies like way mo
which spun out of Google's project
General Motors Intel lots of people are
testing there mostly because the
regulation in Arizona is incredibly
relaxed you know the governor welcomed
everyone in with an executive order
ordering all agencies in the state to do
whatever they needed to do to welcome
self-driving cars to test them the state
unlike in California they don't have to
report data or file for permits all they
actually need is a regular car
registration which is what anyone else
needs to drive a car in the street along
with lacks regulation the weather is
pretty good which helps train these cars
you don't have to deal with bad weather
that can mess with sensors the traffic
is pretty calm and geographically it's
close enough to Silicon Valley that it's
maybe a two-hour flight so it's easy for
executives and engineers to get back and
forth Alex what do you think the
repercussions are for this uber accident
do they do they extend beyond over
itself into the hole signs of
self-driving cars I think the immediate
consequences of the crash should be
contained to Ober especially at this
point since we're not sure about what
exactly went wrong with the technology
if there is something in their software
there's no reason to immediately think
that that would be a problem in Google
software or in General Motors or Ford's
or anyone elses software the
consequences that I do think you'll see
extend are what happens when concerned
regulators and politicians get involved
I don't think that that Arizona very
open climate of to whatever you want
testing will continue for much further
especially since federal legislation is
in the works I think after a crash like
this what you'll see is people writing
those laws will want to have stricter
control over what the cars are doing and
what sort of information the company's
testing them have to share with
regulators and with the public why do
you think there's this big divide from
folks in the tech world that I've spoken
to say uber technology versus way mo
something like 5,600 miles way mo can
drive before some sort of intervention
before you need to physically put your
hands on the wheels compared to over at
maybe 13 miles why is there this big
divide a lot of that comes down to
experience way mo which came out of
Google started its self-driving car
project in 2009
uber started it's around 2014 or 2015
and a lot of it is experience it takes
time to really train these systems to
get them to figure out how to drive
around humans it's hard quickly Alex how
far away do you think we are from this
being you know that from basically these
being part of our lives
I think commonplace is still years and
years away it's gonna spread slowly but
in just a couple of months way mo is
planning to launch a real commercial
self-driving car service in Arizona so
if you're around Phoenix by the end of
2018 well I just want it to be ready to
take my kids to soccer practice get to
that level I'm on board you go they're
not too far okay take you take you on
that Alex Davies thank you so much for
joining us thank you